Bir de şu leonti shewolf eşya okul ve
dersler bu dersimizde okulla ilgili
kelimeleri derslerimizi derslerimizi
yani odaları halinde film fiillerini ve
bazı sıfatları birlikte inceleyeceğiz
okul dersleriyle başlayalım daha 35
Öztürk ışığı tava to a yok kafi ya da et
kunduoğlu geçişte Melik yoğun on then
fonmatik matematik ya da kısaca matı
Bu şimit fizik biyolog iyi
bu konst
bu squat
Ben 10 muzik
Evet şimdi şahıslara geçmeden önce hemen
bir not düşelim Almanca'da erkek
şahısların artık el her zaman içinde
olur kadın şahısların artık elediği olur
ve sonra in gelir birçoğu kelimelerin
her zaman için artık Elise yine de iyi
olur böyle şahıslara geçebiliriz Biz de
şöyle bi şöyle arayın
Ama çoğu olursa cin şöyle
çok değerli YK kille kalk Yani çoğu dil
yaka dişoğlu Kay mı derslikler ve
mekanlar
3D Şule
3D schulhof mekanlar için Almanca'da
çeşitli kelimeler vardır Örneğin gassım
abraka Om daha geniş bir anlamı var alan
O da başka türlü mekan olarak da bu
kelimeyi kullanabilirsiniz diye hale
daha büyük her ya da salon için
kullanılır da size boğar laboratuvar
geho falan ya da Meydan yada bahçe
olarak kullanılabilir bu kelimelerin
önünü Örneğin öğretmen adını koyarsanız
derslere katılma müzik adına koyarsanız
müzik odası gibi birleşik kelime elde
edebilirsiniz ve bu kelimeler her zaman
birleşik yazılır Örneğin dine ha
öğretmenler yastığıma O da biz ve
ikisini birleştirebiliriz ayrı
yazmıyoruz ne hattıma Peki hangi artık
geri kullanmamız lazım değil mi dasma
Her zaman için en son kelimenin
artıkelli kullan
var yani da slagga attım abi Das
artikeli olan bütün kelimeler sonuç Sima
olan kelimeler Bir bakalım lastiğe
katıma
O biraz Klas ıntıma
bu gas müzik sıma
bir diş Fuat Halebi contaları gaz şimila
boğa de komple account
bu gibi biyotik değil mi sa
Ama bunlar mekanlarımız Peki bu konuyla
ilgili kullanacağımız fiiller neler
hapın vefkin fiilleri hamsili Benim şu
gün şu dersim var şeklindeki cümlelerde
kullanacağız finis e bulmak ama
aradığını bulmak bu anlamda Biz diğer
anlamında yani beğeni olarak bulmak Bu
dersi nasıl buluyorsun beğeniyor musun
şeklinde biz bu fiili kullanacağız fiil
çekimlerine bakalım Hafiye düzensiz bir
fiil iş habertu hasta hatmi hapının ihap
ziha bunun sihab ın fiiline bakalım
Düzenli bir fil Bazı yerlerde e harfi
kaynaştırma harfi olarak gelmiş içinde
dur findest finland finland finland
finland zifin derin Artık cümle
kurabiliriz Bütün kelimelerimiz bunlar
Öncelikle ders planımıza ilgili cümle
da bunun için bana One yani ne zaman
soru kelimesi lazım ham fiili lazımdı
Volkan takyan haftanın Gönül lazım
haftanın gününe edatını kullanmayı
unutmayın Ama artı bakın taka montak
amdin stock gibi başlayalım ham filmi
kenara yazdım ve ders programını
doldurdum şimdi One yani ne zaman
sorusunu en başa yazdım One ve sen sen
ne zaman yani senin dersin ne zaman
şeklinde soru sormak istiyorum burada
filmi ikinci pozisyonu yazıyorum ve bu
yüzden de bunu doğuya göre çekmem lazım
hemen çektim vanha stoğu
Şu Dersimin bar has to English İngilizce
dersine zaman bu sorduğu için iş yani
sen dediği için ben de cevap vermem
lazım iş yani özneyi boşa yazdım ve işe
göre fiilimi çektim eş adı iş hab-ı
burada haftanın günü gelmeli ama önüne
edatıyla birlikte iş abı Amon tak dersin
neydi English iş habia montak English
geldi örneğimiz One has to matı diş
hab-ı amdin Stark matı
ne var hastur Fuat
bu iş ağabey amcan hasta konudan fay
taksi Fuat
bu peki bu dersleri beğeniriz ya da
beğenmeyiz çeşitli fikirlerimiz vardır
Onlar hakkında bir fikrimiz vardır Bunun
için ne yaparız bunun içinde cümleler
için şu şekilde Biz evi sorusu lazım
yani nasıl sizin sorusu bulmak ve bazı
sıfatlar lazım tarifimizi yapmak için
öyleyse hemen bazı sıfatları bir göz
atalım out iyi miniş good önlemiş
Koyuncu olumsuz hale geliyor gudini
scoot supap kıyma Klas It All bir dersi
harika buluyorsanız Bu dört kelimeden
bir tanesini kullanabilirsiniz West İş
önemli iştir eşit iş önemsiz Paint
heyecan verici heyecanlı amusant
eğlenceli lan fail iş sıkıcı
bu müzik müzik dersi nasıl buluyorsun
hemen bulmak filmi yazayım ve başlayalım
will sorusu ve soruları her zaman en
başa gelir Wii sen diye soracağım için
fiilimi çektim duya görevi ve Cindy
stoğumuz ikder Siemens ona yazdım wifin
Disto Muzik dua olduğu için iş sende de
için ben de cevap veriyorum iş işe göre
fiilimi çektim iş film müzik amuzant
müzik dersinde eğlenceli buluyorum dedim
fizik dersi nasıl buluyorsun film filmi
yazdım We başa yazdım doğuya göre çektim
değilsin düz Doğu fizik
bu iş keşfin dü dü filmi çektim işfin de
fizik laqua işlem guys sıkıcı deme ki
filmde fizik like var ben fizik
dersini sıkıcı buluyorum dedim Peki En
sevdiğiniz ders nedir ya da bunun sorusu
nasıl sorulur hemen bakalım baba sistein
Lipid Fahri Ping bir kelime önüne
gelirse en sevdiğin anlamını kazandırır
s harfi D kaynaştırma harfi nedir Basit
Daimi peeling fake en sevdiğin ders
nedir bir mali peeling FIFA kist Tabii
ki Deutsch en sevdiğim ders Almanca
[Müzik]
dersimiz sona erdi aynı kind and the
hound Aynı bu kendi ve tüfeğe eline bir
çocuk bir öğretmen ve bir kitap dünyayı
değiştirebilir PDF
çok bekledim Mutlaka onu indirin ve
ayrıntılı olarak onu da inceleyin oyun
linkler üzerinden de alıştırma
yapabilirsiniz Bir sonraki derste
görüşmek üzere hoşçakalın